&gt;&gt; Okay, so clearly we haven't totally forgotten how to solve equations. That's
awesome. It's going to help us a lot in algebra moving forward. Let's look at a
new equation. We have 3 over x minus 1 over 5 is equal to 7. Just like the last
example, we have two fractions, but this time there's not an x anywhere in the
second fraction. We have two choices as I see it, or at least two choices in
terms of how to start the problem. The first choice that I see is the first step
we could take, would be to combine the two fractions that are on the left-hand
side. That's definitely an option. But there's another choice. We could isolate
the terms, or term in this case, involving x on the left-hand side and move
everything else over to the right-hand side. I have a feeling that it's going to
be a little bit less work if we go with the second option. I'll put a link to
how to do the problem in the other way in the lesson notes. But for now, let's
go with this method. So our goal right off the bat is to get this term by itself
on the left-hand side. So for the equation that I want you to write in this box,
I would like you to isolate the term with x on the left-hand side. Get
everything else on the right-hand side and simplify it so that it's written as
an improper fraction. What do you get then?